[Musique]
J'ai entendu dire qu'elle ne recevait pas de
câlins et que nous devions vraiment faire
quelque chose à ce sujet
et oui, je voulais le lui offrir pour
la fête des mères
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
ils ont fait une clé de bijoutier ont 8000 l'école a pris à
tour de rôle le dîner à OPA hamara est
votre distance un mètre kebab signifiait dans
toute la camara de magma EAJA hey cooky
traqué par des questions et des commérages ils D
disent un vélo majeur coupé le long de Gamera
semi-real yo [ __ ] a  meilleur appareil photo sale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
Korona oblige maintenant à repenser la façon dont nous pouvons
faire de l'hospitalité aussi en fait toutes les
autres choses dans notre centre d'art doivent
être reconsidérées mais la nourriture de surf est l'un
de nos programmes  nous avons pensé d'accord,
essayons ce qui se passe si nous avons des villes dans de petits
espaces, est-ce que ça fait du bien et pouvons-nous
servir de manière sûre et ça se passe plutôt
bien en fait
[Musique]